hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 136 if i'm
not mistaken
it is
hot in portland oh my goodness
i have decided that what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna wear
a t-shirt for this podcast and although
that's kind of not in keeping what i'm
going to do is i'm going to define it as
a button down because that's how things
are
yes well that is in keeping with some of
what we'll be talking about today but
yeah you're going full otter today i'm
full full order the otter is riding a
bicycle for those of you just listening
it is it's not a photograph of an otter
riding a bicycle but it is a uh
shockingly realistic depiction of an
otter riding a bicycle yeah not her
being safe looking both ways or at least
looking back over his shoulder yep yep
seeing if he's being followed exactly
exactly
uh well yeah it is um
it is hot as uh as it has been many
places but uh this is super unusual for
pacific northwest here we are yes we i
forgot to point out i'm dr brett
weinstein and you are dr heather heing i
am and you are and today we're going to
talk about sex and gender murder
transition
things like that wikipedia definition
the recession
and the drinking age for young people
awesome i don't exactly see the
connection between these three things
but i'm sure we'll find something
obvious in retrospect i'm hoping
i'm hoping all right so uh
housekeeping first we follow these live
streams uh when we have time as we do
today with a live q a so you can ask
questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com go there now
ask questions we will get to as many as
possible after we end this first hour
hour and a half live stream and then
start with the live q about 15 minutes
afterwards
we um we have this book
out in french that's upside down
this book which in english is this
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
evolution of the challenges of modern
life and um we're doing some more
spanish language interviews not we're
not speaking in spanish because
unfortunately our spanish just isn't
that good and better the interviews have
it's god it's great um so it's coming
out um it's been out in spain since i
think june
and uh it's coming out in many countries
in latin america and u.s spanish edition
either either august or maybe early
september
so that's that's happening and it's out
in french now if you're watching on
youtube we are of course live as well on
odyssey and the chat is live on odyssey
and uh we're everywhere all everywhere
where you find your your podcasts after
that
we have a store darkwurststore.org
where you can find um not otters on
bicycles but other cool things epic
tabbies digital book burnings that sort
of thing
you can find
me my writing at
naturalselections.subtech.com
and we are supported by our audience we
are very very grateful to you and for
you we appreciate you subscribing to
uh whatever what whatever way that you
are watching or listening uh liking the
videos sharing or the audio podcast
sharing them both are full episodes and
uh if you are engaged in the video
consumption of our content than the
clips channels as well on dark horse
podcast clips on both odyssey and
youtube
and uh just a reminder that youtube
demonetized us about a year ago now
and took a substantial part of our
income with it when it went uh so
we appreciate also financial support
from those who can afford it you can
join one of our patreons tomorrow at
11am pacific on sunday july 31st not
today
which is july 30th i had that wrong
earlier
um
we will be doing a private q a the
questions have already been asked but
it's it's small enough we engage with
the chat it's it's a lot of fun it's fun
and it's like a nice little community of
people and it really is a back and forth
banter anyway it's a different thing
it's very cool it is it's it's it's a
lot of fun and uh also at our end uh
before we come back to you next week on
our next live stream brett will have one
of his conversations
uh on saturday morning next yes that
will be the coalition of the reasonable
also an excellent conversation full of
great people many of them have been
there for years wonderful
and at either of our patreons you can
get access to our wonderful discord
community where you can engage in honest
conversations about difficult topics
where you will not be shamed for holding
a position that is a minority position
or a new position or position that you
haven't fully thought out or a position
that you might change your mind about
and we encourage people to do just that
what they find out that what they used
to believe isn't what they currently
believe
you they have book clubs uh happy hour
virtual happy hours karaoke and uh
encourage you to go find a spot around
the virtual campfire and of course we
have sponsors and we are grateful to our
sponsors uh both both new and old all of
our sponsors have products or services
that we actually and truly vouch for so
without further ado here we go the three
sponsors for this episode
[Music]
all right our first sponsor for this
episode is pharaoh life which makes skin
care products from animal fats primarily
lard from pigs
fair life makes a few remarkable skin
products they are unique and highly
effective at moisturizing and feeding
human skin i use face food on my face
and skin food for the rest of my body
just a tiny bit of face food evens out
the texture and it just feels really
good
similarly a little bit of skin food on
cracked fingers after too much gardening
or dry legs or elbows after a lot of
dirty work or time in the wind and sun
feels luxurious and smooths things out
a little goes a long way it's made in
small batches here in the u.s with no
added chemicals or preservatives the fat
is 100 sourced from farms that use
regenerative and pasture-based animal
husbandry which faro is calling smart
lard technology fair life's products
come from healthy animals which in turn
promotes healthy humans and a healthy
planet
if you've got sensitive skin or baby
with diaper rash or a small child with
eczema or have a very active lifestyle
that includes for instance crafting or
wood or metal working or generally being
outside a lot you should try fair life's
skin food
fair life is a young company the first
lard based skin care company and is
eager to promote more products utilizing
smart lard technology including soap
deodorant and lip balm after all the
lard works in mysterious ways
go get yourself some face food or skin
food or both to help restore your skin's
health elasticity and moisture
darkhorse listeners can save 20 off
their first purchase by going to
pharaoh.life darkhorse or applying the
code darkhorse at checkout get
additional 15 savings by signing up for
a subscription to receive pharaoh's skin
food on a monthly bi-monthly or
quarterly basis that's pharaoh.life
darkhorse
all right our second sponsor this week
is bubs naturals bubs naturals sells
three products that are becoming ever
more popular in fitness and outdoor
exploration circles collagen protein mct
oil and apple cider vinegar gummies
there are a lot of companies already
selling these products but bubs is
different here's how the products
themselves are of the highest quality
carefully and sustainably sourced and
bubs is a company with a conscience
bubs is named for navy seal glenn bubb
glenn bub doherty who was great friends
uh with people from all walks of life
including one of the founders of bubs
naturals for 364 days a year 10 percent
of all profits go to a charity in
glenn's honor and on veterans day that
number is 100
bubbs naturals encapsulates glenn's
enthusiasm for life self-improvement and
helping others with the motto feel great
do good
try bubs natural collagen protein which
is truly unflavored and soluble and i
will say it is shockingly unflavored and
very soluble
i have tried it and it's awesome
unlike some of the collagen proteins on
the market it's got just one ingredient
which is critical for joint and gut
health and muscle recovery and you can
add it to anything a glass of water a
smoothie a cup of coffee i have added it
to water and coffee and i've sometimes
added it to water with
apple cider vinegar which is a very good
way to do it
and bubs naturals collagen protein is
sustainably sourced from grass-fed
pasture-raised cows in southern brazil
very far from the amazon
if you are looking for a soluble soluble
flavorless protein to help with for an
instance post-workout recovery this
could be just the product for you both
the collagen protein and mct oil are as
easy to add to coffee for the boost that
you are looking for
be it mental focus or muscle and joint
wellness and recover recovery
furthermore the apple cider vinegar
gummies have been a huge hit with many
of our friends and family everyone who
tries them seems to want more bubs
naturals aspires to the words
die young as late as possible i think
that is a brilliant slogan
perfectly with the
senescence
logic of life
go to bubbsnaturals.com and use the code
darkhorse at checkout for 20 off your
order
excellent our final sponsor this week is
mudwater that's mud wtr mudwater is a
coffee alternative made with mushrooms
herbs and spices it's got a seventh the
caffeine is a cup of coffee and you get
energy without the anxiety jitters or
crash of coffee and it's delicious
each ingredient in mud water was added
with intention it has cacao and chai
lion's mane cordyceps shaga and reishi
turmeric cinnamon and more
this is a terrific product i really
enjoy it either on its own or as a warm
drink in the morning black or with cream
or honey or both and it's not just for
people who don't want coffee or trying
to give up coffee i i enjoy my coffee
and i also enjoy my mud water there's
definitely a hint of chocolate in the
flavor and the masala chai blend
including ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves and lightly lightly lately i've
been blending it into a smoothie with a
banana and ice some delicious locally
made entirely nut milk mint and cacao
nibs it's completely delicious and
they've got a wonderful new
caffeine-free product designed to be a
drink before bed which i also love mud
water is 100
usda organic non-gmo gluten-free vegan
and kosher certified mud water allows
you to build a morning ritual that
promotes sustained energy without the
crash
so visit mudwater.com darkhorse to
support the show and use darkhorse at
checkout for fifteen percent off that's
mud wtr.com
darkhorse
and or use darkhorse at checkout for
fifteen percent off all right now before
we get going i realize there's something
i forgot to say last week that i should
have um i did an interview on a
product that no one will have heard of
called qpark that's an acronym
and i did it with the uh the author and
uh
the
uh
it is his brainchild what does that make
him the brain father of q park
paul arans
anyway it is on his channel but i think
you should look at it among other things
in there we have a discussion which i
did not see coming but nonetheless i
think was interesting about the utility
of q park which is a mechanism for
leveling the playing field in arguments
and the question that uh paul raised was
what would be the utility of such a
thing
uh in the context of the
argument that we have with sam harris
and so in this i invite sam uh to
potentially use this software in order
to have out the argument that we have
been headed for for so long um
and anyway i hope many people will go
look at it we will provide a link to
that video in the description uh if
you're interested in this i've been
involved in the project for quite a
number of years i think four years now
at this point
um and it is uh almost ready for prime
time if you're interested in the project
sign up for
uh the q park twitter account and the q
park youtube channel and you can hear
more about it as it develops now what
you've written down there looks like a
very unusual spelling of the word that
you're using
yes as i said it's a it's an acronym for
a process how is it spelled no one is
going to be able to find it if you don't
tell them
i should tell them now yes okay yes um
it is q
p
a r q q it's that terminal q that's uh
that's the surprising q which is not
followed by a u
an e a u or an e right it's not it's not
followed by much um and the initial one
is followed by the rest of the acronym
but it's not non-terminal yeah exactly i
know this has been fascinating to people
uh who have been wondering how you would
spell q park if you were to set out to
do such a thing given that you're trying
to send people to q park it's uh it's
important it's not a word that anyone's
heard before because presumably paul and
his uh what do you call him brain father
he's the brain fog yeah his his uh his
his his brain team
uh came up with that word maybe he did
on his own but uh it weren't say just a
spelling no that's not yeah no it tends
to be what you do but i will say i think
it is a a truly terrible name for this
piece of software but i will point out
that many of the most important features
of our world have terrible names it's
becoming another uh google oh okay
google the beatles the beatles the
arguably the greatest band in the
history of rock and roll their name is
predicated on one lackluster pun it's
not a good name but great band
so anyway i think the uh it would have
felt better about them if it had been
predicated on two lackluster puns i
would have been i would have felt much
better about it if they'd been
predicated on a single excellent pun
that would have been fine right or
something obscure you know the doors
that's a good name right
the doors and not the beetles the doors
beetles
okay oh the doors of perception the
doors of perception right so there's
something important yep um so yeah i
think the beatles had a terrible name
but succeeded in spite of it it's almost
as a hobby handicap of rock and roll
kind of phenomenon
that's not going to make any sense to
anyone but you but you got it yep
here we are yes okay shall we talk about
murder
of course all right we always start
there we always start there
the new york times reported this week on
a two-time violent killer who upon
release from prison at the age of 81
went on to kill again
wow tragic
um and
and the killer is a woman which is both
tragic and very unusual so i'm gonna
just read the first five paragraphs of
this um article if i why is it hiding
from me now where did it go why does my
computer do this to me um it's the
interface with the
the streaming computer okay here we go
um
zach yeah you can show this again or
show this now i don't know it's a little
jumbled at the top but maybe that
doesn't matter i don't know why it's
doing this so this is the new york times
uh
piece this week
how did a two-time killer get out to be
charged again at age 83
marceline harvey is accused of
dismembering a woman in brooklyn her
life was defined by a tormented
relationship with women and herself and
a simmering anger
this is published yesterday
and here are the first five paragraphs
of the article
the person before the parole panel in
june 2019 was tall and slim in far
better shape than 81 years of life might
have suggested
mild and polite the supplicants seemed
nothing like the murderer who had spent
decades in prison first for shooting a
girlfriend dead in 1963 and then for
stabbing another in 1985 stuffing her
corpse into a bag and leaving it in
central park
i am no longer that person the inmate
told the parole board commissioners
despite misgivings they would rule in
favor of release
two and a half years after leaving
cayuga correctional facility marceline
harvey was accused again charged with
killing susan laden 68. part of ms
laden's body were found in march inside
a shopping cart in east new york stuffed
in a bag in miss harvey's apartment
investigators found a bloody mop a tub
full of towels and a box for an electric
saw
for seven decades leading up to her
latest arrest ms harvey navigated new
york's intricate criminal justice
bureaucracy the country's largest police
apparatus the state's overlapping
welfare agencies its prisons and the
officials charged with deciding who
remains in them
she confronted the system in some
moments manipulated it in others behind
her was a trail of crimes so grisly that
for decades parole officials refused to
let her out
now ms harvey has pleaded not guilty to
murder ms harvey's lawyer at the
brooklyn public defender's office
declined to comment on her case
ms harvey who was being held at rikers
could not be reached for comment she
declined an interview request
so that's the first part of a long
article of which i will share more
shortly
um
but
this is an amazing story very unusual
very very unusual um and so i actually i
looked up
i've got the fbi statistics
uh from 2019
on
on homicide
homicides by sex that are single victim
single offender crimes only so this
obviously is not a single victim crime
and i strongly suspect that these
numbers i'm about to share would be even
more strongly skewed in multiple victim
crimes
but i wasn't able in the short amount of
time i was looking to find um multiple
multiple victims single offender crimes
uh but what i what i find from 2019
again on the fbi site is male offenders
out of a total of i don't have the total
written down here but male offenders
in again single victim single offender
homicides were numbered 5839 and female
offenders were 683 which is actually
higher than i was expecting
and when you do the math on that that's
ninety percent ninety percent of uh
single victim single offender homicides
as log as recorded by the fbi in 2019 90
um had men as the offenders
which makes uh
which makes a female um
homicidal maniac uh rather
rather completely unusual
well it's probably much more unusual
than that statistic as i said right but
because of the definition of homicide as
opposed to
murder
in other words a justifiable homicide if
somebody is being attacked and they kill
their attacker that counts as a homicide
but not a
and so there may be many i would i would
guess that that is distributed unequally
too i don't know but i agree i agree and
of course i mean there's there's a lot
of there are a lot of places where you
can find statistics
and uh i went with the fbi imagine from
you know from before covid uh just
imagine that they would be somewhat uh
somewhat clean i'm sure there are
reasons to object to their their numbers
as with any ones but there you go
something like
uh 90
of homicides
uh with one victim and one offender are
um are done by men
but if we go back to that article
here we go we go back to the same new
york times article and i'm just i'm
reading here from a pdf so that i could
highlight some the very next paragraph
says decades worth of police documents
and court records records detail the
life of ms harvey a transgender woman
who transitioned at some point after her
release from prison
central to her tale are more than three
decades of parole board minutes obtained
through the state's freedom of
information law in them she insists that
authorities exaggerated evidence changes
stories about crimes she admitted and
veers between a contrition and blaming
those she killed the records include
several examples of her harassing or
attacking women throughout her life she
was accused of attempted rape at 14. the
victim was an eight-year-old girl
ms harvey who by her own account
struggled with her mental health said
she had to choke down rage when women
challenged her manliness before she
transitioned making fun of her soft
voice for example
um
talk about burying the lead this is
unbelievable
they
i mean it's the same damn pattern that
we have discussed before with for you
know
obviously the context is entirely
different but
um chelsea banning who was bradley
manning
the crime for which she was imprisoned
happened
in her mail form she transitioned
afterwards so even if you give
full credit to the idea that a person
can transition from one gender to the
other there is still a historical fact
right what chelsea manning did had
nothing to do with giving
um secret documents to wikileaks right
bradley manning did that and in this
case the person who engaged in the crime
for which she was incarcerated for all
those years
crimes was a man
yep and frankly still is
uh this i mean this is
but even if we this is this is [ __ ]
right um and you know a considerable
risk of being a broken record on this
topic uh how is this kind who is this
kind to how is this compassionate who
does it serve to pretend that sex
uh isn't real and that violence against
violence against women
by a man who is engaged in violence
against women his entire life is in fact
violence perpetrated by a woman no this
you know the
only the only possible
crime that this homicidal maniac
has committed that could plausibly and i
think that would be a stretch but could
plausibly be suggested to have been
uh
performed by a woman by a trans woman is
the last one after after the release
from prison at the point that the person
was already in their in their 70s i
believe this is total incoherence it's
farce and it's tragedy right it's it's
tragedy and farce at the individual
level at the justice level and at the
society level
so
well and that's
this we are in
we are seeing and you know there are
there are a lot of ways
that we will be
mocked for saying that this is one of
the canaries in the coal mine that this
is one of the horsemen of the apocalypse
but
this is this this is the way that the
west falls
everyone
every child and every adult knows that
sex is real and that sex is binary and
that however you decide you want to
express yourself doesn't change what you
are
i would add to that that
the behavior of the new york times in
obscuring that fact and pretending that
there is a different fact which is not
even logically coherent
is um the equivalent of a journalistic
crime right this is as uh we always
point out the supposed paper of record
and the point is this isn't any sort of
record this is a fairy tale being
presented as the record of something and
i would i would point something out to
the extent that all adults
all reasonable adults understand that
there are differences between males and
females
think about the consequence of
pretending that one can simply
transition by saying i'm i've moved from
one category to the next what does that
do to the statistics well one thing it
does is the number of murders that are
uh perpetrated by women is going to go
up right now those aren't murders
perpetrated by women right at most they
are murders perpetrated by trans women
but the point is whose bill do they go
on right is there a problem with women
becoming more violent no there's a
problem with men saying that they are
women and remaining violent or something
like that
obvious prediction which i am certain
would be borne out if if the fbi for
instance started collecting data on
um
on
gender is the wrong freaking thing to be
using here yeah but
homicide by
offender male female
trans woman trans man
obviously what you would have leading
the way would be men
and trans women with
women
um
you know proportional to their
representation in society below that and
trans been probably lowest of all yeah
that's a it's an important prediction
yeah and uh
we are just
it's not even like we've been in like a
relay race and we're like passing the
baton to the next
the next country that wants to pick it
up we're pretending the baton never
existed we're pretending all sorts of
things about
about who we are and what we are and how
life works that is rendering us
like i said farcical
we look ridiculous because
even at this point we'll talk a little
bit shortly but you know even the the
very liberal famously left-leaning
countries in scandinavia are now pulling
back from a lot of this gender insanity
they they are and again we'll we'll talk
we'll talk america is just like
remaining staunch we are we are
remaining staunch in our deep confusion
yeah and it is you know as we have
pointed out it is a revolution that is
at least
it is probably emerging from academia
which is uh
bizarrely
taken over by that particular false
notions and and has increasingly been so
over decades but this is now taking over
the sciences
as i somewhat famously said in uh mike
nana's documentary on the evergreen
affair this has spilled out into all of
civilization we have
you know activists uh district attorneys
refusing to charge people for crimes
basically blaming society for
their bad behavior etc
but this also so a couple things are
true one the ability to even say what is
true right you could say hypothesis men
and women are not substantially
different right
but then you make it impossible to test
that hypothesis if you confuse the
question of who actually is male and
female right so that's what's happening
at a statistical level but there's also
a way there's something in the story
that comes from a very different thread
something that's bugged me for for
literally decades i do have more to
share about it too but go for it now all
right
we
when we deal with punishing people right
when we imprison people
ought to be defining two categories
some people can be rehabilitated we
ought to take the possibility of
rehabilitating them very seriously and
we ought to invest in the structures
that actually succeed in rehabilitation
whatever they may be it's a discoverable
answer
and then there are lots of people
who aren't rehabilitatable they are
psychopaths in the worst case
right
why did this person get out at all
right crimes that grisly
certainly suggest that somebody is
completely is beyond indifferent maybe
they delight in you know in murder and
dismembering and so the point rape and
sexual assault and sexual assault all of
these things so the question is even
let's say that there was a 10 chance
that that person was rehabilitatable and
that they somehow violate the trend that
we know from so many other psychopaths
right there's no reason to think that
that's a category but let's say it was
it's still not worth risking other
people's lives on that gamble they've
done enough to justify keeping them away
from civilization for the rest of their
life
why was this person even eligible to be
released given that they cycle as far as
we know modern psychology tells us a
psychopath cannot be rehabilitated so
why are we pretending otherwise when it
comes to our legal system well um to be
fair to the new york times uh
this is a point they make now they're
deeply confused about what the sex of
the homicidal maniac in question is and
they claim that that's a difficult
question to think about but the real
question which is simpler is exactly the
one you just raised okay
just a few more bits from the piece
quote a homeless shelter worker and
people close to miss laden questioned
whether despite her gender identity ms
harvey should have been placed in a
homeless shelter for women given her
history of attacking and murdering them
speaking from rikers to the new york
post ms harvey referred to herself as
having two personas one a violent male
named harvey marcelin the name she used
for most of her life and is included in
court records and the other is
soft-spoken woman named marceline harvey
so
born in 1938
ms harvey spent her youth in new york
wrong
the child of a single mother even as a
teenager she displayed a propensity for
violence particularly toward women and
had a complicated gender identity
who the [ __ ] cares yeah sorry
according to court records and parole
board minutes ms harvey no was treated
at catholic charities which paired
clergy and lay people with troubled
children after
the attempted rape at 14.
now that paragraph
i was obviously adding a lot of
editorial
commentary
while i was reading it but that
paragraph on its own ending with
uh
was treated at catholic charities after
the attempted rape at 14 makes her sound
like a victim
at the time this was harvey a 14 year
old violent young man who attempted the
rape of an 18 of an eight-year-old girl
this is this is
this is journalistic malpractice as a
young adult ms harvey described that as
a tall slender man
lived with her mother and earned no not
described not described
accurately observed to be
not described wrong like none of this
none of this makes sense in early 1963
ms harvey was again accused of rape this
time as a 24 year old
this time as a 24 year old
man they should say right and it goes on
and on
the problem here is even to the extent
right and i i always bend over backwards
to do this
correctly though i think at some level
this it's got it's they've jumped the
shark falls under my rubric of you don't
have to take sophistry seriously
but
the fact is right if we say
gender is the software of sex
right
that only goes so far right that
linguistic trick they played there with
the rape the attempted rape at 14 where
because she is described as female
uh the
she is the presumed victim in that
paragraph right
that
is not about software
right the fact is it may not be
impossible for a woman to rape a man
but it is certainly much less probable
at the level of morphology
right the fact is an intermittent organ
is uh
not a matter of opinion it is something
that is either present right and
therefore can be weaponized or not
present and the point is the new york
times years later doesn't get to pretend
that that's nobody's business because it
was apparently central to the incident
just point of order uh biology speak may
not be everyone's language and you did
not say intermittent organ although that
is one possible um interpretation of
what in fact the organ is as well
intromittent organ uh is an organ that
can penetrate and is a penis or if you
happen to be a squamate if if some of
our listeners are in fact snakes or
lizards uh uh hemi pins two of them
i don't think we have that many squamous
listening but i hope so i mean maybe
maybe some of our listeners have squam
mates attending to them
that is possible yeah that is possible
so intro mutant organ is what you said
and it's not it's it's not a matter of
opinion
it's not a matter of opinion and in fact
the question of what prison to send you
to
got a penis
no women's prison under any
circumstances i don't care how you dress
i don't care how many shrinks have
diagnosed you the point is that's a
hazard to women yeah right
you know if you've had it removed
we can talk about whether or not you
just decided you were a woman or
you know
that's a long-standing issue there's at
least a question then but
no the if you are an intact man the idea
of being sent to a women's prison
because it's how you say you feel what
universe have we landed in that's insane
this is actually relevant uh if you put
my screen back up again zach this is a
picture from the same new york times
article this is marceline harvey the
supposed woman
who has committed all of these terrible
crimes check out that trans woman
pattern baldness she's got going on
there
i mean that is quite something yeah um
i'll bet to um
i'll bet there are other problems she's
having maybe um hearing loss typical of
older trans women i'll bet she doesn't
quite have the bone density loss that uh
older trans men are often finding
themselves afflicted with yeah
you know why
because these are anatomical and
physiological descriptions of what
happens to
men
and women as they age
men are far less likely to experience
bone density loss as they age
osteoporosis and such and women are far
less likely to experience male pattern
baldness and hearing loss especially at
the higher frequencies so you know just
just look at the hairline
other you know in addition to everything
else about this person again a homicidal
maniac by every definition
and know that this is not a marceline
despite the fact that he decided to
switch the order in which his names go
well the
the new york times
clearly demonstrates that they are
just simply
suckers because this person's history
demonstrates that there is a complete
absence of moral constraint yep if
somebody has a complete absence of moral
constraint enough that they can murder
and dismember other people
multiply
then
we are talking about somebody who might
find
lying not that big a deal right right
and you know okay so this person is
lying yep um even in the case that
they're not somehow that this is an
accurate report from inside this person
has denied other people their entire
lives and done so apparently in cold
blood yes so
uh you know yes i would assume that this
person is probably lying and if they're
not the injustice done by not taking
their
stuff seriously is a tiny one compared
to the injustice that they have done and
they're intact and everything and it
just the story is absurd
you know how i used to say
certain stories diagnose the system
this is one such story i believe so too
yeah um and that's actually perfect a
perfect place to end and decide what
segway segway into talking about um
tavistock um but first just two more
short quotes from this new york times
article ms harvey quote presented as a
mild spoken very tall black man said
anne brennan the nurse who ran the
intake i said well why are you in the
women's shelter
apparently quote apparently his feelings
and identity were far more important
than all the other women that were
terrified of him
she said
and uh next thing we know there's
another woman dead
so uh this
this does feel a little bit like
uh the moment when a lot of people woke
up when
uh what's his name who won the swimming
competition pretending to be a woman
leah thomas leah thomas yeah uh where
just the pictures made it so clear and
you know there was there was no violence
here there was injustice but there was
no there was no tragedy at the level
that we see here but it was really
patently clear when you just put the
visuals and the story in front of people
right so
let us hope let us hope that uh that
that this wakes some more people up
we see
the segway here we do see the tide
turning as i alluded to
earlier uh over in
transitioning of youth space not in the
u.s yet hopefully that will happen soon
but the infamous tavistock gender
identity clinic in england it is
the big gender identity clinic and it
has taken a lot of flack from a lot of
good people who have gotten no end of
flack in return um has been ordered to
shut down by next spring
why why by next spring why not right now
but okay it's been ordered to be shut
down and this is extraordinary so yeah
go for it yeah i just want to point out
that the idea
that
this clinic is apparently engaged in
procedures
that are egregious enough that it needs
to be shut down
raises exactly the question about if it
needs to be shut down what about the
procedures that happen between now and
when it is shut down right and this is
reminiscent
of what happened as
mandates were lifted over covet and so i
want to point out this is now a hallmark
of how goliath behaves when it's caught
red-handed
right so it can be caught it can be
forced to change course
it cannot be forced to admit that it is
changing course and the way it makes it
appear that it's just simply involved in
something normal rather than a tacit
admission that it was full of [ __ ]
is that it sets a timeline which makes
it seem like oh this is just another you
know bureaucratic date on the calendar
rather than oh my god this clinic has
been injuring young people and needs to
stop yesterday not a month from now much
less you know eight months or you know
whenever whenever spring counts as you
know beginning of spring is still
what seven eight months away yeah more
than that um
so i i don't know i mean uh we need we
need better language for this but
goliath sucks is
basically where i am with it yeah
yeah glad sucks and it hides behind its
own bureaucracy uh in order to to
maintain a semblance of
businesses no as usual that's just the
things it has a very this is boring
business as usual there's something in
the future it's not that it's happening
tomorrow because we suddenly realize
we're maiming children yeah exactly so
there's there are a lot of there are a
lot of pieces of the story and it is uh
i will link to several of these
in the show notes and we're not going to
talk a whole lot about it now but i will
show you for instance i um i first heard
about this from the gen spec press
release sock which you can show here uh
which is which is quite
quite careful it has all of these links
on it
in which so gen spec is an excellent
organization
which is
which is at the forefront of the
question of
the question of the conclusion that we
should not be transitioning children and
that we should not be encouraging
children to question what they are on
the basis of a fleeting
you know flight of fancy
um but among among what they have here
actually if i may zachary have my screen
back for a moment thank you
they've got a times of london article
here
tavistock gender clinic forced to shut
over safety fears this is published
just a few days ago july 28th
the nhs the national health service in
england is shutting down its gender
identity clinic for children after
review found that it failed vulnerable
under 18s
uh it has been ordered to close exactly
as you said and this is due to a report
put out by pediatrician dr hilary cass
who is leading a review of the service
and i also have that review uh which i
will which i will post um
to
the show notes it's very long it's very
detailed she and her team went and did
interviews and assessments and also all
sorts of all sorts of the right sorts of
investigations as to whether or not
this this clinic
which has been
patently
hurting children for a long time now
should continue to be the one and only
place that children who are presenting
with some kind of gender dysphoria in
great britain should be sent to and the
conclusion was a resounding no no they
should not there need to be more options
there need to be more options besides
affirmative care which is if you wake up
one day and say you're a turtle you're a
turtle nope not that if you wake up one
day and say you're a toaster you're a
toaster nope not that if you wake up one
day and say you're the sex that you are
not well then yes we have just the
puberty blockers and then cross-sex
hormones and then surgery for you it's
insane and finally it is stopping at
least in great britain or it will be
soon so
related to goliath hiding behind its uh
bureaucracy we are also watching
everything foundational right the things
that we all once agreed on being undone
at every level and so with the mandates
we saw what i specially amended the
vaccine mandates we saw what i argued
was a double violation
of nuremberg because not only did
informed consent not exist in the
context of the vaccines in question but
those who refused to administer them and
in some cases take them were in jeopardy
of
their uh their jobs so the obligation to
resist immoral orders was itself being
being
punished and in this case we have what
is an obvious violation of the
hippocratic oath right right the fact is
the purpose of this clinic was to
violate the hippocratic oath right now
it may be and i i agree with the
following statement
if you are one of those rare people who
is gender dysphoric and is going to
reach adulthood and remain
compelled that something is not right
right
you need help and the earlier we give
you that help likely the better it works
so i do have compassion for people who
experience this early and know it but
it's a very tiny number of people and
the problem is that this clinic
is not
acting with caution with respect to yes
there are a tiny number of those people
and we need to sort them out and find
them in amongst the vast sea of people
who are momentarily confused about their
gender
instead the point is affirmative care is
a euphemism for a violation of the
hippocratic oath
right the fact is this is
doing physical harm right just
measurable harm disrupting the
reproductive capacity the sexual
well-being uh and capacity of these
people you know altering
destroying functional tissue and
replacing it with at best a simulation
of the other sexes
uh
hardware
right that is harmful
right wha what happened to first do no
harm well it got obscured by affirmative
care which you know who's not for
affirmative care it sounds like
preventative care right well it ain't
sounds positive yep sure does yep
not yes but yes and we're going to say
yes to all the things including
affirmative care yeah i will say um you
know i made i made some of those
arguments in
in and zach you can show this briefly
this piece that i wrote it a lot earlier
but i published in my sub stack in
november of last year protect children
do not allow them to medically
transition
in which i make um you know precisely
this argument
which is that
even though
there will be some
very rare people who are actually going
to live a more fulfilled life
by existing as much as possible as the
sex that they are not
and those people will presumably know
that pretty young
we risk far more harm to far more people
by ever allowing children or youth to
transition
because
those errors will be much much much more
numerous
and i would add one other thing to it
which is
even if we were to take the trans
activists
at face value and imagine that there is
a huge increase in the number of people
in this category it it immediately
invites the next question which is
what's causing that
and to the extent that there is
something causing it that is novel
the question is can we figure out what
it is so that we don't do this to any
more people yeah what happened to
diagnosis and prevention well you know
in fact
gosh have i ever heard anyone in this
argument talk about preventing
transness where is that right like and
because it has been
because it has been slid in as if it's
the next civil rights battle as if it is
um inherently who you are this will
sound you know i will be called a bigot
for even saying that because i wouldn't
say i'm trying to prevent homosexuality
no
right but transness appears to be a
malfunction well a a dysfunction between
between your actual sex and either what
your brain understands or something else
that happened in development i would be
i would be a little cautious about that
because we do have many cultures which
have
this category and so i would argue that
the increase is almost certainly the
result of malfunction but not every case
is the result of malfunction or at least
we don't know that yet yeah i don't i i
don't think i agree with that now we do
have i mean in fact we do know and i've
written about in a couple of other
essays
uh for instance genetic anomalies as in
i think dominican republic uh where we
actually can can track oh there's a
there's a lot of people who uh you know
the what is it the machiambras who i
don't remember which way it is i think
um are born appearing to be
um
male and then become female and puberty
become visibly female in puberty or
maybe it's the other way around i can't
no i think that's right um and so you
know that's that's a that's a
malfunction
that's a genetic malfunction
there's a question about it um
we have this pattern in many cultures we
also have
[Music]
a question about
just as we have in many species the
production of more offspring than adults
can manage to feed right so there's
basically selection is playing a game
where it doesn't have enough information
about what the future will look like and
so it biases in a direction and we have
that game
also played with respect to the balance
between the sexes and so in cultures
where
there are too many men and not enough
women or vice versa the idea that some
group of people
can switch categories and be paired up
and that's the society makes allowances
for that could arguably be a very simple
play the role without actually being
able to fully play the role because you
know
born female you're never going to
produce sperm no but born male you're
never going to produce it's at the right
level it's the level you would expect
selection to fix the problem which is to
say we will treat you this way but
nobody's confused about what it actually
means i see i see this as a possibility
under under rare and very particular
circumstances so
uh so okay i i i see that point to you
uh the the bigger point right now is as
you said uh the incredible rise the
incredible rise in people claiming to be
trans and
some of it as has been you know very
very well discussed by all sorts of
people including us i think is about
social contagion but there's also the
question of what we are doing what we
are doing society-wide that may be
prompting this and the fact is
that we are flooding our waterways with
endocrine disruptors
and with um what art for many people
cross-sex hormones right our waterways
and our airways are flooded with garbage
and
the point
airwaves is really what i mean yeah but
the point is yeah we are do we are
treating
this sensitive developmental process
with complete disregard we are ignoring
the fact that the harms are
uh
quite clearly the most likely cause is
novelty
novelty in this case
and
also to the extent that one can say what
i said which is
the transness exists in many cultures
there's a reason that you might expect
it to emerge right so it's not
inherently pathological but even in
those cases i am not aware of a case
in which
uh either pharmaceutical or surgical
modification is the response and so to
the extent that somebody believes that
they are in this other category
not altering them first doing no harm
allowing them to transition supporting
them in so doing but leaving open the
possibility that if that doesn't turn
out to be what was bugging them that
maybe they get to go backwards
right that has to be left open and the
idea that somehow not only are we going
to embrace that some huge percentage of
the population uh has this condition and
that we are
we are obligated morally to address it
early but that we are obligated morally
to redress it irreversibly is you know
it's three steps insane yeah now it
really truly is
uh you know we are
everything about what the west and now
you know specifically the united states
is doing on this front is
uh wrong-headed increasingly
irreversible
ignores reality and
uh and everything that has come before
and
makes us look like idiots yeah and uh
and and puts us at risk
of far more than simply being laughing
stocks of the rest of the world
right and we are you know
how how dumb is the predicament right
you either get to look like an idiot for
taking this seriously in cases where it
clearly is not what it appears or you
get to be a bigot right in what universe
is that your choice
right that's just that's evidence that
somebody has a limit that has erased a
possible category because they don't
want anybody in it and the fact is all
the reasonable people
have skepticism they have compassion
they are trying to navigate the
difficult question that's not bigotry no
right no it's it's not and um i actually
increasingly as we've had this
conversation i'm wondering
about the complete lack of discussion of
um addressing root causes and preventing
and preventing because
other than the activists who are leading
the charge
i don't think
that people
like people who actually are living you
know the the few people that
we're i and we are still in touch with
who are living as trans people
would say
this is a better life than if i weren't
dealing with gender dysphoria yeah i
don't know i don't i don't think i met a
single trans person yeah who had that
perspective right and i will say we know
uh newly so we knew a number of trans
students
we newly know uh blair white and buck
angel who are
i don't know well i i've met blair white
a couple of times i have never met uh
buck angel in person but we certainly
interacted
electronically but anyway i think
they're doing a very good job they're
you know politically very far apart from
each other they're doing a very good job
these are two people who are
have transitioned very compellingly
right and they are very open about what
it is and what it isn't in any way i
think that they provide a pretty good
model for how to discuss these issues
without losing your mind yeah i think
that's probably true i haven't paid um a
lot of attention there i know a couple
of people who aren't public personas who
i'm not going to name here who i'm
thinking of
who struggle mightily and live
live as the sex that they are not
knowing that they are not the sex that
they present as
and um
and wish that they didn't
have to yeah right and
uh you know all decent people will have
compassion for that predicament and
uh frankly all reasonable people will
also agree that you do not take a
child's word when they wake up one
morning at face value and send them to
the clinic
and you know think
thank a lot of people for working hard
for many years
to get tavistock shut down in the near
future and hope that that begins to
cause the rest of the dominoes to fall
yep
absolutely well all right um let's i'll
i'll hold off on the rest of that
conversation you
want to talk about among other things
wikipedia oh wikipedia yes wikipedia um
which was
i would argue until recently and have
argued many times the
greatest encyclopedia in the history of
the universe by uh orders of magnitude
um it was never perfect
it was never perfect but now
how do you assess i'm just going to
interrupt here how do you assess
quality of
encyclopedia by orders of managing that
feels like adding a quantitative element
here that has no place it's so easy okay
right
the question is how encyclopedic is it
and you know pick another encyclopedia
and it's still encyclopedic though isn't
it so that's not the question
well no no
it so
two things have to be true let's say
that it covered every topic in the
universe and uh
at random that it had an entry for every
topic and it was lorem ipsum in every
entry right okay that might be
technically encyclopedic but it's not
meaningfully encyclopedic right
now to be fair if you pick up the
encyclopedia britannica you will find
some slant in there those articles are
written by people those people have
perspectives those perspectives are not
completely excluded from the
encyclopedia britannica and they were
never completely excluded from wikipedia
either
wikipedia had a kind of a
you know there were certain topics and
there still are certain topics you can
go to to get a
textbook
level explanation of
something right if you want to know
about uh atomic orbitals
right my guess is you can still go to
wikipedia and you can
see the diagrams of the various orbitals
you can
see a description of how they affect
covalent bonding etc all that stuff is
probably okay because it's probably not
that political now at some point
somebody is going to decide that certain
orbitals are transphobic and then
everything's going to go to hell you
won't be able to go to wikipedia but for
the moment there are certain topics that
you can still go there and find a
reasonable entry
and there are other topics in which
you just can't right because something
is at stake and the mechanisms whatever
they are behind the scenes result in
complete gobbledygook happening and uh i
won't say too much about the covet stuff
at the moment you and i are
still i have not been to wikipedia in
some time and looked at it but i believe
we are still being actively slandered by
wikipedia with no mechanism for doing
anything about it um uh over things that
we said about covid which uh we stand by
we stand by and have largely been borne
out by the evidence more and more true
with every passing week right
so um in any case what emerged this week
was that same
noxious behavior on a different topic
where it was immediately visible to a
bunch of people and the question was one
of uh
are we in a recession
right
now what happened was a prior the
recession
are you like
has any human being
walked around in the u.s in the last six
months and actually wondered
that my dear is not the question we all
know six months ago technically we
weren't because well what's the
definition you were going somewhere
but the point is wikipedia itself
reported the standard definition which
was two
consecutive quarters of reduction in gdp
okay
technical boring economic whatever here
is the problem with that definition okay
right the problem with that definition
is the midterms are coming up oh no and
what if we were in a recession what if
quarters what if the midterms happened
during a quarter
holy crap
this is really awkward yeah so i don't
know who decided to put the midterms in
a recession but somebody screwed up yeah
so the solution here is it was the
people who brought on the recession
i don't know but nonetheless
it cannot be that the biden
administration will be forced to face an
election in a recession that's just not
fair that's team blue god damn it okay
no it's not fair so what they have done
is they have argued that although some
people will tell you that a recession is
two consecutive quarters this is now
biden administration not wikipedia
correct okay the by demonstration has um
changed the definition that they
ascribed to
the the definition is now
uh it is a decline in general activity
as uh discovered by the uh
um the nb
uh the national board of economic
research the general activity general
economic activity yes well look
let's give them their due
just like walking around like what's
activity here
yeah it's economic yeah it's it's
productivity it's it it's trade
i don't think that this is probably it's
probably a multivariate
measure multivariate would be okay if we
could all agree on what the variables
were but the problem is this is
subjective by saying
that this particular entity has to
discover a and you know it's got two
subjective elements right over the
period of several months you have to
have a general decline in activity now
that may actually be if if those weren't
two subjective measures that not only
lend themselves to being gamed but are
also there to be defined by a particular
entity which can therefore presumably be
captured and probably is and not to be
redefined at any moment that a person
wants to come in and say no we're not in
a recession are we right so the point is
it is a subjective recession that we are
not in we're a recession an objective
fact then we would be in one because
we've just had those two quarters and
you don't have to take anybody's word
for it you can just go and look at the
two quarters and say ah okay so this is
standard politics i mean it's
increasingly terrible and ridiculous but
this is you know this is unfortunately
team blue standard politics team red
would do the same thing or something
like it i'm sure if you know if they had
the wherewithal and the were currently
had the power to do so
how does that relate to wikipedia well
wikipedia went about changing the
definition so that it
matched uh team blue's
self-uh serving fantasy of how
[Music]
economics works yeah so zach do you want
to show the
um the two screenshots from wikipedia
yes you do want to show the two
screenshots from wikipedia
well start showing them
all right
keep talking man yes um i am now talking
about the fact that there are
screenshots which will show that if you
now go to the recession entry in
wikipedia not only does the definition
reflect that it is the national board of
economic researchers job and you know
it's not like the national board of
economic research has says we're not in
a recession they just apparently haven't
done the analysis yet so
okay so we're these are coming out of
order this is what happens if you click
if you go within
wikipedia's recession entry
it says that there is a
disagreement about the definition and
then if you click through you get to
some media outlets have circulated an
outdated version of this article
claimed to be its current state please
check if claims or screenshots you have
seen are consistent with what's actually
here okay
so
they've changed the definition inside of
wikipedia they are now putting warnings
on
uh the circulation of
the
earlier objective definition which did
not require you to ask anyone if we're
in a recession
and
look
the game is obvious right the game is
completely obvious which is the point
the facts
are obviously not facts we have a
team
that wants
complete power to define what is a fact
and they are perfectly willing to take
things that are wrong and say they are
true and they are perfectly willing to
take true things and say they are wrong
right they have done it repeatedly in
this case what they've done is they've
said
again so you're talking about wikipedia
now
uh why are you talking about
politics team blue
and it's affiliates in tech right we
have wikipedia the greatest encyclopedia
the universe has ever known i swear by
orders of magnitude on the basis that
you could look up
you know orders of magnitude more things
and find credible information and that
went on for many years never was it was
never perfectly
perfectly objective it can't be but it
is now
a weapon of war it is a weapon in a
political war which means several things
it means
one
in the space where we need
that greatest encyclopedia that all
humanity can go to and just agree on the
basic facts of what's going on right the
foundation of knowledge the library of
alexandria to which we all have access
that thing doesn't exist because there's
something with its name sitting in that
niche a giant parasitic glob is sitting
in that niche slandering people who are
trying to tell you what you need to know
redefining things so that the only thing
you are left with is somebody else's
subjective assessment which is obviously
you know i mean imagine
imagine trump
runs in 2024 right then the point is the
logic behind the scenes is going to be
nothing that increases the chances that
trump will win can be allowed to have
the status of a fact and we are going to
see the same [ __ ] that we saw over
hunter biden's laptop right that same
thing is going to emerge again and is
going to take over our ability to have a
basic conversation about where we are
what pathogens we face what we might do
about them
where what our economic economic
standing is
and you know you can't run a
civilization this way right this is
this is going to run us
absolutely into the ground and so
what i see is
they've done us a favor
we lived through this with covid for
years okay we lived with them
manufacturing nonsense and parading it
as facts and forcing
people to
subscribe to them
right
follow the science that's what they told
us in this case
what we've got is follow the economics
where the economics is as defined by a
particular agency who gets to say we are
or are not in a recession and i will say
i know nothing about the national board
of economic research i am
hoping that the universe has been wise
enough to put someone at the head of
that agency named simon so that this can
be the obvious game of simon says that
it is and we can all recognize that we
are being had and what we need are
independent economic authorities who are
capable of telling us what's really
going on because that is necessary for
us to steer the ship yep
so do you want zak to show any of the
other screenshots that you had pulled up
i don't think i don't think they're
necessary at this point um you all at
home get the gist of uh of what has
taken place
uh oh i will say yeah you want to show
the npr screenshot okay
so i will say npr reported on the story
and um
it reported on it in a way that i found
uh troubling much as the the way the new
york times reported on the the
uh
murder
homicidal maniac the homicidal maniac
story thank you yes that you were
describing and the point is it says that
wikipedia has locked down the edits and
they specifically imply that it's a
bunch of people who
have newly registered accounts who are
disrupting this rather than wikipedia
itself
intervening on behalf of the biden
administration oh come on npr yeah wake
up
wake up well npr here says what is a
procession wikipedia can't decide um and
i just well while you were talking just
then i went to the wikipedia page
um
which which is consistent with what you
said but it's it's interesting to
actually read what the wikipedia page
says in recession can i can i share this
yes now what i would we don't we're not
in a position to do it but i would love
to do is go back and see what the recent
changes to it have been because many
people including elon musk have noticed
that this is going on and so this is
obviously a hot potato for them of
course uh so the second paragraph zach
you can show my screen if you like the
second paragraph of wikipedia's current
entry as of july 30th 2022
on recession reads although i guess i
get a little bigger for those
watching at home although the definition
of a recession varies between different
countries and scholars two consecutive
quarters of decline in a country's real
gross domestic product is commonly used
as a practical definition of recession
okay
in the united states a recession is
defined by the national bureau of
economic research as quote a significant
decline in economic activity spread
across the market lasting more than a
few months normally visible in real gdp
real income employment industrial
production and wholesale retail sales
in the united kingdom it is defined as
negative economic growth for two
consecutive quarters
uh so
that
that in the united states of recession
is defined by the national bureau of
economic research thing is this little
like slight of slate of words there in
which you know why do we care what the
national bureau of economic research
says well
so and they go that goes to
uh
the nbr's recession dating procedure um
but why are we going to them at all
why are we go so
again i'm not i'm not arguing
that they might not have a more useful
measure right what i'm arguing is that a
this is designed to look like something
so technical you couldn't possibly care
about it okay so different economists
are battling over which measure to use
do you want to use gdp alone or these
other
you know the composite measure
i'm not arguing the composite measure
might not arguably be better what i'm
arguing is that not only is this now an
explicit appeal to authority right gdp
is something that you can you will get
an uh supposedly uh objective measure of
its uh
what is the rate for the last month
or last quarter
um
you can go from there and figure out if
you're in a recession right in this case
you have to go to these authorities
right so that's a
that is an
anti-scientific move
what's more not only is it these
authorities are going to tell you based
on these categories which they will have
to assemble in some sort of a formula
that will weight different things and is
prone to be gamed right well don't look
at the model behind the curtain
nice
that's very good um but not only
are you going to need a formula that is
going to take a bunch of things and
is is ripe for gaming because you could
down weight things that suggest you are
in a recession and upward things that
suggest you're not
blah blah blah blah blah and you know
there will be arbitrary differences the
recession may lag the measure may lag in
certain
parameters and so those parameters could
be prioritized if you wanted it not to
be a recession sure
but the fact that they've introduced two
subjective
phrases in saying even what that formula
is going to look like right so it's a
significant decline it's a significant
decline over the course of many months
that means right that's you you you put
two
wiggle walls two to ten depending on
what we're trying to maximize right it's
it's it's an utter absurdity um and you
know an obvious game and obviously
anybody who is doing that is not your
friend they don't want you to know if
you're in a recession they want you to
think you're not in one whether you're
in one or not which itself is i mean
this is presumably not the point but
it's it's a form of gaslighting i mean
they're trying to gaslight the american
public into thinking that we're not
experiencing what we're experiencing
when we go to fill up our tanks with gas
or buy milk or bread or
observe
uh
that
like somehow a lot of people are out of
work and yet also there's not enough
labor to fill positions uh and you know
this this is this is one of the ways
that presumably they're able to to gain
the numbers because like oh well
unemployment isn't that isn't that high
well it's because most most people who
are unemployed haven't been seeking work
and so they drop off the unemployment
numbers after i can't remember how many
months like they're not counted right in
the number of people who are unemployed
anymore if they're not actively looking
for work yep
um
anyway in any case um so
i just i want our our listeners to keep
their eye on the ball the transition
from objective measures to subjective
measures is what somebody who wants to
game your mind is
going to do
and the problem with using something
like wikipedia in this game is that it
means that not only is wikipedia a
dangerous weaponized source but the
opportunity for a competitor to arise to
do the marvelous job that wikipedia was
built to do
is uh
it's very unlikely that that will occur
and the cost of civilization of us not
having a trustable
uh wikipedia
is almost impossible to calculate the
value that comes from having a truly
encyclopedic encyclopedia that at least
aspires to be objective and as complete
as possible yep um is it's a tremendous
loss no it's not the same as saying well
you know go back to the 90s there wasn't
a wikipedia
why won't it be like them because we
have had it and we and it still looks
like it did to most people and so this
is not like okay well we just don't have
wikipedia anymore this is living in a
world that is post wikipedia and still
most people assume that wikipedia still
still exists as what you have described
as the best encyclopedia the universe
has ever known greatest encyclopedia of
the universe has ever known by orders of
magnitude yeah yeah
all right i miss it i will say that oh
yeah indeed yep okay you had one more
topic that you wanted to talk about
today which was
the drinking age oh yes the drinking age
um i feel
that
i
have now lived enough years that i
should definitely i don't know what the
drinking age is but i feel that i have
attained
the right to have a drink really yeah
not now okay now not now no it's too
early
what i really wanted to talk about
was
something that occurred to me so let me
just say
this thought is an old thought and it
didn't start with alcohol it started
with
quote unquote drugs okay
where i always felt a bit betrayed by
the fact that i was told that drugs were
dangerous i of course then
tried pot at the time pot was a pretty
mild phenomenon and my thought was out
they were full of [ __ ] they were lying
to me about drugs being dangerous and
the problem is many drugs are dangerous
and somebody needs to really sit you
down and say look
here are the dangers of uh
pot here are the dangers of
the powders here are the dangers of the
hallucinogens right so you have some
idea what landscape you're even in and
that by having this policy that
basically tries to keep you away from
drugs that they're creating the gateway
drug phenomenon like i was just going to
say you know the this is your brain this
is your brain on drugs
ad campaign that we grew up with uh
made marijuana into more of a gateway
drug because some people
um like like you describe your own
experience
hold off for a while and then upon
finally trying it went like oh my god
that's not a big deal what's the deal
and i will also say i find this
uh
complexifying but
i now believe that marijuana is a much
more dangerous drug than it was well it
is it has become a much more because
there's been human selection for
uh not only an increase in thc but an
out of whackitude of the thc to you know
other um
psychoactive compounds the other you
know cbd and cbg in particular i think
um and the others that we haven't even
named yet uh which mean that um you have
more of the sort of psychotic inducing
aspects of marijuana and fewer of uh you
know fewer of the tempering effects that
made it you know made an interesting
plant and also not all that strong yeah
it sure ain't ditch weed
right now yeah it's a whole different
thing and so
um you know there's still a discussion
to be had about whether it's anywhere
near as dangerous as something like
alcohol but the
potentially profound effects that modern
uh pot has are not comparable so uh you
know the absurdity is comparable to to
what it was you know the absurdity of
reefer madness
at the time
right
is being lost because the fact is now
it's at least a profound drug um it can
be yeah but the point is okay so that's
the the long-standing thought about why
why do we say drugs that's not cool
you're misleading young people and uh
you they need more information not less
well and i'm sorry but like
also you know there's a whole lot of
legal drugs
that you can get your doctor to give you
that are really dangerous oh true and uh
you know street drugs versus pharma
drugs
is not
a proxy for dangerous versus not
dangerous right really really isn't and
in fact in some of the cases it's the
same damn drug right right right so you
know some of the adhd stuff is really
yeah pharmaceutical
meth pretty much and
um and you know we deal with it in in
totally different ways but
all right so here's the the modern
thought
the modern thought is
there's a there's always been something
weird about
the
drinking age being 21 in the u.s
it's weird you know if we're gonna draft
you and send you
overseas to to attempt to kill people
and risk being killed right that does
suggest that you're ready for a certain
amount of responsibility
it's also
not effective right people who are not
21 typically do not respect the drinking
age they end up finding ways to drink
and
my sense is they get into a lot of
freaking trouble and here's the question
the question is
if
we were to allow so first of all the
alcohol molecules which we discussed on
the uh on the podcast a couple weeks ago
right these o-h groups oh we're gonna
talk about isopropyl yeah when we're
talking about it do not drink the
alcohols are
uh oxygen hydrogen pairs sticking off a
saturated carbon right a carbon with all
of its
electrons covalently bonded
or all of its outer electrons
that
alcohol molecule in ethanol right it's
all pretty interchangeable in terms of
its effect right that is to say the
alcohol the ethanol in wine and the
ethanol in vodka is not different in
fact the uh heart alcohol is distilled
from uh a pro you know the
microorganisms can only take you so far
because they die from alcohol poisoning
you know at 12 or whatever it is yep and
so you have to distill down further to
get rid of more water to concentrate the
stuff
and the point is look
um
dear young people
we understand that you're gonna drink
we understand that you're probably gonna
get drunk probably more than you should
and you're probably going to go farther
than you should and you're probably
going to learn some ugly uh vomity
lessons and we wish you wouldn't but you
do that only once and learn the lesson
right may you learn the letter may one
trial learning uh be the the lesson of
your drinking career
um however
why are you in such a freaking rush why
do you need this stuff concentrated
right
the concentration has a problem built
into it which is that it makes it very
hard to know the instantaneous measure
of how drunk you are
lags
how much how drunk you're going to be
based on what you've already consumed
because it takes time for the stuff to
hit your blood right so it is very easy
for somebody who is not experienced with
this stuff
to drink
uh
too much because at the point that they
make the decision to take their last
drink they haven't fully understood how
drunk they are
right or how drunk they're about to be i
mean some of the logic of course maybe
you're getting here is for the same
reason
that
pot was selected to be very very strong
because it was cheaper and easier to get
illegally across borders if you needed
less volume to get a sufficient amount
to get people high across borders
if it's illegal for young people to buy
alcohol
they have a better chance of sneaking a
fifth of vodka into a party than they do
of bringing in a case of beer well that
is not a point i was going to make but i
think it's a truly excellent point it is
the same kind of selective effect of
prohibition it's just a different
prohibition that has caused marijuana to
become concentrated and caused alcohol
to be or concentrated alcohol to be
preferred by young people in many cases
but here's the question
if we
had a two-tiered drinking age right so
that you were legally allowed to buy
beer wine and hey if you're sensitive to
wheat try cider it's really good but you
need the dry stuff people think you want
a sweet side or you don't you want a dry
cider but
brett likes it's so dry it's sandy yeah
is is gritty
my son so our 18 year old producer son
says he is alerting us that uh
apparently i don't i haven't fact
checked him but uh he is alerting us
that until what he says is the mid 20th
century
that there was a two-tiered drinking age
all right so let's just say i don't know
that that's true i haven't heard that
before if so that's really interesting
information it may be that that date is
wrong i would imagine we would know it
if it was really mid 20th century i
don't know i've never thought about this
but anyway doesn't matter the point is
i believe
that
so there are two problems with the
concentrated alcohol one it's much
easier to make a big error right much
easier to make and this is in fact why
beer than liquor never sicker liquor
than beer never fear the point is if you
start drinking the slower to hit your
system stuff
and then you move into the stuff that's
harder to calibrate you're much more
likely to make an error
whereas if you step from the harder
stuff to the uh less concentrated stuff
um it slows you down
well you're you're also adding water
into your system right so that's what
i'm saying staying hydrated um keeping
your body a little cool getting up and
walking around um and you know even just
like oh i have to get up to move to get
myself another beer is you know helpful
in the process of not getting alcohol
poisoning right so the
the fact is it's not like you know the
molecule is the same right the question
is how much
water it comes with
and more water is good it keeps you from
getting dehydrated and therefore hung
over it slows you down so you're much
more likely to detect oh maybe i've had
enough and the point is it's it's a
better training exercise so
it seems to me that we should have a
two-tiered thing that the question is
the number of people we lose to either
alcohol addiction where they get out of
control with it or
death because they exert bad judgment on
it or any of the other problems that
arise
how much harm could we reduce if we gave
people the ability to
experiment with a lower caliber alcohol
earlier in life before we granted them
the ability
to buy the higher caliber stuff
yeah i like it
all right i think it's right
and apparently it used to be the case
apparently it used to be if zach is
correct he doesn't he doesn't tend to be
wrong on things that he proclaims like
this so yeah he uh i find he is
frequently right sometimes that is
annoying as hell sure but um he is
frequently right about things so i could
say the same thing about you
wow yeah yeah all right okay you could
say the same thing about me
i ca i could and i do
all right
um i think we've reached
the end wait no no one more thing there
was breaking news that was delivered to
me right before the podcast i think we
should at least touch on it have we
broken uh we have not broken okay um
something is very broken in the state of
denmark denmark um
here's a piece of information i suspect
you don't know oh
you remember joe biden
yeah yeah
joe he's got he tested positive again i
tested positive again he had what was he
oh he
he was on pex 11 wasn't he well but
here's the question was he
i think so but here's the question hey
i think that look i don't know that i
don't trust anything that comes out of
this white house or the tests like even
if they're being totally straight with
us the tests are crap but right yeah i
don't know that they wouldn't oh my god
have reason to pretend but let's just
say that this is for real and maybe it
is just for real maybe they're for once
telling it to us straight he got coveted
he tested negative he's now tested
positive again
um and that i mean that matches the
thing that happens with with pexlebut
virals yeah but
these people are dumb enough to give the
president paxlovid
i mean that
that's news to me right that's an i
these people have access to good
information
they can get the drugs that work if they
want they don't have to take this
you know
frankinese [ __ ]
that they've assembled in the lab
because they can patent it frankiness
it's like a
frankenstein
uh enzymatic oh frank and ace yeah
frankenace sorry
oh i see i see yeah okay no it's not a
good turn that's not gonna catch on
it's not going to catch on we can agree
to that but um but enzymatic chimeras
right yeah they can get him whatever
they want and these people
believe me they they lie like like
they're drinking water they could give
him ivermectin hydroxychloroquine they
could just
tell us you know that that they're
giving him you know all of the latest
fancy stuff from
from pfizer and merck and everybody be
happy but but i think when you take
either of those two
drugs that you just named i think you
actually sprout a maga hat on your head
isn't that right oh wow i don't know
turns you into some kind of crazy
conspiracy theorist okay okay prepping
republicans suppose that's true science
denying wait
no
some of those things but let's say let's
say that that's true okay so the man's
sick he's president they don't want him
to die because they don't have anybody
to run his place in 2024 among other
reasons okay so there's an op-ed i think
in wapo today um saying actually what he
needs to do is to say before the
midterms that he won't be running in
2024 because that's the only way the
democrats have any chance of maintaining
any
any any kind of power and i think i
think the problem is as much as he
totally sucks everybody else in the
party does too so
presumably not everybody else well it's
real close but uh in any case a lot of
us are running away but there's no place
to run to right that's the running away
part is easy they're running too that's
a that's a much tougher call but okay so
suppose you're right and if you take ira
mectin and hydroxychloroquine because
you've got covid that you sprout a mega
hat but can't they fix that in post
i would think so i mean they've got they
got people yeah they've got they've got
technical chops they totally do yeah i
mean remember that beautiful set uh in
which they pretended to be
vaccinating the president in a beautiful
austere room in the white house no i
never saw this picture no
oh there was a picture from an awkward
angle where the president is clearly
being injected with something in a
potemkin room and you know it just
really summed up the whole the whole
covet experience
yeah all right okay well that's it so
that's the breaking news yeah that's
that's the broken news
that's the brokenness that's the broken
noise
i mean i guess the uh the other thing
that they're now they the they the
christian anderson and company they are
making another bid for
um this is definitely zoonotic this
definitely came from the market and
wuhan and we're not racist but this is
definitely about what those people eat
and you know not about the fact that we
created this damn thing in a lab and now
the entire population of the entire
planet is going to be living with it
forever
yeah now
uh we we will return to that topic very
soon okay
we will um yeah
i think i think we are now there okay
we're now there so we're going to take a
break uh for those of you
uh who are watching us live if you want
to take a break for 15 minutes or so
come back we'll be here with a live q a
you can ask your questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
[Music]
you can join our patreons
if you are interested in doing so you
can get access to our discord we have
that private q a tomorrow
at 11 a.m pacific on sunday july 31st
and brett has his couple of uh more
intimate conversations coming up on
saturday and sunday of next week the
first first saturday and sunday of the
month exactly um
we encourage you if you
don't know that we spent that much time
today really getting into you know
evolutionarily
um
deep things but everything that we do is
inspired by the evolutionary thinking
that we lay out in our book
so if what what are you smirking about
i'm sparking about the fact that they
have they rob us of all the terms that
we need and the problem of being
inspired
right like now everything
asian inspired
it's a term that people who are full of
crap use and so anyway are you kidding
me we're going to defend it
we are actually inspired
i'm not
jesus no you are not inspired now you
should i'm really not no
okay
and i can't i can't end with the the
things that i say at the end on that on
that note so you have to say something
better say something better yeah you
have to say something better before i
sign off um
friends
it can't get much worse
hey everyone
despite what you've seen here today
do be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
you